[Music]
from the guy who made the first few
episodes of the walking dead
comes a film so quietly hopeful
deliberately paced
and unassuming it totally bombed in
theaters cause everyone went to see
speed instead
what even is a shawshank redemption
sounds like a southern wrestler's
finishing move
and look at this
the shawshank redemption check out
number one on imdb's top 250 films list
because the users on that site have
barely seen 250 films between them
that's nevertheless a masterpiece that
gave dudes everywhere
permission to cry their eyes out and
lets every tough guy pretend they do
time with the quiet dignity of andy
dufresne
when in reality they'd be the first fish
to crack then knark on red for a pack of
cigs
officer that kindly old man tried to
give me a rock hammer
i think he's gang affiliated you gotta
get me out of here
travel back to a time when the prison
system locked up innocent men for life
subjected them to physical and sexual
abuse and was more interested in
profit than rehabilitation i need this
new highway contract
wait how's that different from now oh
why i mean right
and meet andy dufresne the biggest dork
in shawshank history
and we mean big as tim robbins hides his
nba level height
to make his ass look kickable he'll
spend his life sentence carving chess
sets
listening to opera doing taxes and
correcting people's grammar
don't read so good you don't read
so well that all helped to cover for his
escape plan
because no sane guard wants to do a deep
search of the prison athlete spanked in
ew return to a time when morgan freeman
was old enough to play a grandfather
but young enough to date a granddaughter
in his brilliant performance as
red an honest crook who loves two things
his best friend andy and narrating his
thoughts to no one in particular
i have to remind myself that some birds
aren't meant to be caged
their feathers are just too bright wait
is he
is he talking to me oh a cool red
let his soothing baritone turn a
terrible story full of rape and murder
into a poignant story full of rape and
murder
prison is no fairytale world he never
said who did it
but we all knew that ends up feeling
like a greek tragedy
told entirely through asmr videos i hope
i can make it across the border
i hope to see my friend and shake his
hand
i hope the pacific is as blue as it has
been in my dreams
i hope yeah you know if you start
scraping a hairbrush
i'm just gonna pass right out so dive
back into the septic tank for this
classic saga of one film's quest to win
an oscar
only to lose out to forrest gump that
was criminally underrated when it came
out because oscar-worthy dramas are like
a box of chocolates
they sound good but you've had your feel
after two or three
in this genuinely great film about never
giving up on your shitty pipe dream
this is a shitty pipe dreams because
sometimes shitty pipe dreams
do come true
starring hashtag to frame the police
morgan not freeman norton futilities
hillbilly felony put your hand on that
wall
arthur conzarelli brooks and don
and after the coveted restrictions get
lifted
[Music]
prison break
so uh are we sure andy didn't kill his
wife we know he was drunk outside her
house with a loaded gun eight bullets
documented anger problems zero alibi and
he never shows any real sadness about
her death
are you the ultimate dc movie fan come
prove it while winning real money
on the fandom 5 trivia show from
superman to wonder woman 1984
sign up to test your knowledge of
live-action dc history
achievement unlocked survive 2020.
that's when things got knocked into 12th
gear
you know i have one simple request and
that is to have sharks with freaking
laser beams attached to their heads
these boats are made for walking
christopher walking